Look at that beautiful
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Today inshallah this morning we are
going to begin
in the book of salah of alwis. So we are
we finished the book of purification
and now we are starting with the book of
salah. This is not a small feat because
we have
reviewed
almost
100 pages of knowledge of the Quran
and Sunnah. And so being that we have
finished purification,
purifying oneself, his body, his
clothing, his place of salah from
various types of filth, making
all of these various rulings in Islam
and various scenarios, the things that
invalidate a person's woo the things
that obligate or necessitate that a
person make all of these things we
discussed.
So now we are transitioning into the
book of
him.
[Silence]
So the author tells us, he breaks it
down for us. What does the word salah
mean? What does this word mean? We use
this word often. What does it mean?
Well,
in the Arabic language,
it essentially means to pray or to make
dua
for something good. So you say that a
salah is dua is asking is praying,
right? And it has been used
in its linguistic sense in the Quran.
But usually when a salah is mentioned in
the Quran, when a salah is mentioned in
the Sunnah, it is used in its
legislative and Islamic meaning. What is
that? The author tells us that a salah
is defined as a
group of select statements and actions
which are begun with a with saying
Allahbar and they are ended with a
and it has very specific parameters and
conditions. Interesting.
Does any person here
not know what a salah is?
I think that we all know what a salah
is, right? You will not find these
things defined in the earliest books of
the scholars.
So the first book of f ever written ever
was the book of affe
that's the first official book of
you will not find anywhere that he gives
us a definition of salah gives us a
definition of zak gives us a definition
of fasting gives us a definition of Hajj
gives us a definition of why because
these are things that are well known.
Every single Muslim knows these things.
These are not things that need to be
defined.
However,
this became the
the a priority to very later scholars.
They started to define these things.
Why? Because as knowledge becomes more
and more refined and as is as it is
deliberated more and as it is
contemplated more and as it is discussed
and debated more, it starts to file down
and it starts to become more sharp,
right? And each aspect of that knowledge
starts to become you know taken to
its extreme.
However, these things, if you were to
ask a regular person,
what is a salah? It's asking a
regular person, what is bread?
We all know what bread is, right? Do we
know how to define it according to the
definitions of a botonist or the
definitions of a worldrenowned chef in
the sciences of no we don't know how to
define but every one of us knows what
bread is correct likewise every one of
us knows what what salah is and so these
definitions they are mentioned they are
mentioned anecdotally in passing but
these are not necessarily a priority
because we all know what salah is. There
is one benefit though to these
definitions and that is that
based on how we define it we are going
to build upon it. So notice for instance
he says
salah
is a set of statements
and actions
which are initiated by a and ended with
aim.
So now we know that in order for it to
be considered salah it has to be
initiated with Allahbar those exact
words
and in order for it to be complete it
has to be ended with
it cannot
be valid without these two parameters.
Right?
come soon.
He says, "And the obligatory prayers,"
meaning daily prayers. There's more than
this obligatory prayers but daily
recurring as daily prayers. They are
five
and and
these prayers are named after their
time of day after movements of the sun.
So bor is afternoon
is evening
and is sunset and is early night and is
dawn. That's exactly what they translate
to and that is why they are named with
[Arabic recitation]
that
the prayers as five daily recurring
prayers and every day and night they
were obligated on the night of
does anyone remember what night what
year was
what year 10th year after hij does that
mean that there was no salah before that
absolutely not salah
was one of is one of the first
obligations in all of Islam.
What was
done on the night of Isra making it into
five daily prayers that? That's
what was changed on the night of Isra.
Does it mean that there wasn't any
prayer before that? There was prayer in
the first year
after his prophethood. Sallallahu alaii
wasallam. Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
commanded him with salah. And the second
or the third chapter of the Quran to be
revealed is
what does Allah say to him?
This is right.
And so salah was obligatory from the
very start. However, making it into five
prayers divided up throughout the day.
This was on the night of
which was in the 10th year
after prophethood three years before
hijra.
He says that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
first obligated it as 50 and then it was
reduced and reduced until it settled on
five prayers in every day and night. And
it was then called out, "Oh Muhammad,
indeed no obligation, no ruling will be
changed before me."
And so being that it was obligated at
first as 50 and now it has been reduced
to five as an allowance,
you will make five. You and your nation
will make five prayers, but you will be
rewarded 50 prayers. Allahbar,
every single salah we make is at least
10 times if it is accepted by Allah. If
you make it to where it is accepted,
you will be rewarded for each prayer at
least
10 times. Right now, we made salah. If
it was accepted by Allah, this means
that we essentially made 10
times.
10 times. He says,
[Silence]
He tells us that a Bedwin man once came
to the messenger of Allah saiam
who was out of sorts and he asked, "Oh
messenger of Allah, tell me what Allah
and inform me of what Allah has
obligated upon me in terms of prayer.
And the prophet sallallah.aii was
responded the five daily nightly
prayers.
That is what is obligatory upon you.
Except if you want to make more than
that, you are you are allowed to right
etc.
However, what has been obligated upon
you is the five daily prayers
and